far below the ocean's surface an elite  team of oceanographers explores the  briny deep the skilled submariners are  led by this man welcome  world renowned environmentalist and  educator philippe cousteau  great big story presents a marine motion  picture like no other ocean arts  engage learn the mysteries of the deep  from the elite crew of mariners  magnificent  shot in magnificent aquascope see the  submarine world like never before in a  vision so fantastic the life you know  may never be the same  we are people  right  nice and easy now  i think one of the infants has taken a  liking to the ship so he has  the aquatic world with philippe cousteau  coming to  greatbigstory.com on october 20th